again uh good evening everyone um I uh
you probably thought that this title is
a bit weird because it refers to the
hell but if you read the abstract of the
talk you know that the hell in this case
it's just a literary reference to a
medieval poem that is nam that is titled
The Divine Comedy and that has as it as
its first part The Inferno precisely the
H in
Italian this is the poem tells of a
story of a travel in the afterward this
afterward he is shaped by the uh the the
theology the Christian theology so it is
divided in the hell the Purgatory and
the heaven and uh this poem The Divine
Comedy was uh written by an Italian
named dantari and every Italian student
has a read The Divine Comedy at least a
part of it at some point in his
education and so when I started to when
I had to elaborate somehow about my
disappointment as a data scientist his
literary Masterpiece became a sort of
Endy template to fit in my frustration
as a data scientist this is an
opinionated talk and uh of course um
what you will hear it's precisely my my
personal opinion I hope that there will
be some time during the Q&A uh to to
discuss what would be instead your map
of H for from the point of view of a
data scientist I turned into data
science uh about three years ago
previously I used to be a I used to be a
um um a science writer and before that I
used to be
a um and before that I used to be a a
researcher and uh both are fields in
which you always end up with uh
different perspectives so I thought I
was quite used uh to deal with people
for which things different meanings and
yet when I turned into data science I
realized that if you put people and data
in the same sentence the most awkward
things are going to come out and Vis at
times has also been a source of
frustration and Vis talk is a sort of
outspoken response to V A frustration uh
but it is also a try to make a sense of
the not so positive experiences had
sometimes as a data scientist and to
somehow put on the table the data
malpractices that I have encountered and
uh to uh to make a list of them for
myself and also to take some
satisfaction because um this this
Inferno by Dante is the place where
according to the Christian theology the
Sinners are punished and uh uh in in Vis
Inferno there is a
it is structured as a funnel and in this
funnel there are Nine Circles where the
Sinners are located and these Sinners
according to the Christian idea are
pished for eternity in all and the
punishment are assigned by Dante
according to this contrapasso law that
is to say the Sinners punishments either
resemble or contrast with the scene that
was committed
um in the uh at least in dant H the uh
the Sinners the the severity of the sins
committed uh increases going from top to
the bottom and so at first you meet the
people who did uh things not so bad and
at the bottom of the hell you find the
people who did Very Bad Things um I will
use Visa template to uh somehow
bring to the four nine data malpractices
that I've encountered as a data
scientist and that I really really
disliked so I would like to start with
the first circle of hell and in with the
first circle of hell I would really
place the people who do not pay
attention when when they create data
files in particular uh the people who
create invalid CSV files because it is
quite uh quite often you hand up with
people who use commas within the data
fields uh without escaping them properly
and this of course makes the the file um
not properly readable uh this I I I feel
that these people deserve a punishment
and the place inel because um it means
that they don't think about what CSV
means that is comma separated files and
also because evidently they don't check
our data files once they have created
them and for this very reason I think
that they should be punished it by uh
having to replace by hand every single
comma that is a separator in a semicolon
so has to avoid problems and they have
to do it by hand this is a task that is
going to take quite some time especially
uh when the CSV is big and I think that
but of course they are in L and so
according to the uh the Christian
theology they will stay in L For
Eternity and so they have all the time
available in order to uh to do the job
and I think that in the end they will
also understand why data scientist
thought that they deserved a place in El
one level know the people who create
invalid CSV file I place the people who
um who don't um don't leave an an empty
data field empty but feel the necessity
to fit a placeholder in it I find this
people uh the the work of this the
action of these people especially
problematic because it creates a lot of
trouble when you have to clean the set
and mostly because you get totally
disappointed because checking for empty
values is usually the first thing you do
with a new data set and when once you
have a placeholders that somehow hides
the missing value you are at first
convinced that your data set is very
well made and then you have sadly to
realize that this is not the case and
you have even to spend time in order to
get out of these placeholders and to get
the data that in the conditions in which
in the condition in which it could have
been given to you that is without
placeholders for the missing values I
think that a right punishment for these
people is that they should be constantly
reminded that there is nothing wrong
about not knowing things and admitting
it and therefore they should leave a a
missing value uh for a missing value an
empty data field in the one level of
behal below I place what I call the
standardization villance that is to save
people who don't pay attention when they
do data and they don't adopt proper
standardization measures this in this
category I put the people who use a
multiple version of the same country
name the people who confuse physical and
political geography the people who use
multiple formats for date and time
cleaning a data set for which no
standardization has been employed in the
making is a lot of trouble uh and Visa
trouble could have been easily spared if
because there is something called The
International Organization for
standardization ISO in brief and Vis
organization has been in existence for
over almost 80 years and if you browse
their website you find find an answer
for very many standardization problems
in terms of data and so I think that the
right punishment for these people is to
learn by heart all the ISO standards in
particular the country codes the
currency codes and the date and time
formats because these are the three
types of information that most of the
times you encounter and that are usually
a lot of trouble if you don't um if you
don't have them properly standardized in
a data
set one level below I place the people
who create far far too long identifiers
and uh in this case I mean the people
who um who uh use something that is very
important that is a unique and
persistent identifier but do it in a way
that becomes counterproductive because
if the identifier becomes to long or if
you try to put too much information into
it and people need an encyclopedia in
order to understand what kind of
information is embedded in your data uh
in your identifier then I think that
this is really missing the point and
this is the reason why I think that the
right punishment for these people is to
provide help desk support 247 and until
the end of time for the identifiers they
created because they have to listen day
in and day out to uh the the people who
call them and ask what does this mean
why it is so uh why it was created so
and they have to repeat and repeat and
repeat what this identifiers mean I
think that in as a at the end of time
they will have also uh they will also
agree that sometimes Simplicity is the
key to
success we are now going to the the
fifth level of the L and I would say
that at this point we are switching from
sins from the previous sces that I could
I would call venal because if people had
been more uh had paid more attention
could have been spared to uh scenes that
are structural because they uh they they
there is something really wrong in
working with data for instance in this
case not using metadata and
this is uh because if you have a data
set and you don't have metadata that
describe this data set or you have an
insufficient amount of metadata to
describe properly the data set then your
data is basically Inus and I think that
the only punishment for these people is
to be forced to do a meaningful analysis
of a data set that was ended them over
without metadata think INF this data set
is a data set of measurement and the
column adders don't have the units of
measure for these measurements this is
basically an impossible task and I hope
that this will be a way to convince them
that metadata really have to go with
data and as it is recommended by whole
of the usability guides about data one
example are the fair principles of for
scientific data
management and one level below I place
the people who ignore machine
readability when I started working in
data I took that everyone had to do with
data shared the idea that machine
readability was a an essential
requirement I had to um I I had have
learned that this is not the case there
are many people who work with data and
don't don't think enough about machine
readability uh this is of course a
problem because if the data are not
machine readable it becomes a problem to
work with them and I think that the
right punishment in this case is that
these people are uh asked to transform
an heavy a non machine readable data set
and I can think as an example at an
heavy formatted workbook and they need
to make this transformation into machine
readability without committing any
mistake without making any mistake I
think that this task is basically
impossible to accomplish because you
will never you will be you will never be
able to have a perfect transformation
given all the tricks and all the uh
somehow customized solution that you
have to come up with in order to make
your data machine readable and so I hope
that uh being given an impossible task
they will also realize that mure
readability is really a non-negotiable
requirement when you work with data one
level Below in Vell I place the people
who ask invoke apis as if apis were
magical tools able to solve all data
problems these people in my experience
do not have a clear idea of what an API
is but they probably read somewhere that
API are helpful when you work with data
and so they ask you an API but they
don't tell you what are the source and
the target systems systems for your API
what amount of uh data traffic you
should expect and also in the hand who
should query Vis A Pi uh this is of
course this of course doesn't make the
the work possible and I think that the
punishment the right punishment for
these people is to ask that them to
answer truthfully they cannot lie two
questions the first one is why do we
talk about things they don't understand
because I think that the bottom line is
is that they are talking about something
for which they have no technical
competence but building a data
infrastructure is really a technical
task and so the solutions for instance
building or not building an API should
be left to the people who have the the
expertise to make those choices and
should not be somehow HP randomly and
the second question is why the data
science why should the data scientist be
the one to build an API I don't think
personally that the data scientist is
the better best person to be an API
there might be cases where the data
scientist can help and has relevant
expertise but I think that in order to
make an API that is the reliable state
able and scalable uh you need to have
also web development competencies data
engineering competencies and not
necessarily a data scientist has his
competencies it's just a data guy and so
has to do everything but I think that
this give me an API philosophy is really
not going to bring uh to bring value and
I hope that the punish people people we
realize
that in the we are now in the second
last circle of hell and here I place the
people that I dub the AI
Fanatics I uh these people uh are the
those that Advocate the use of AI
without really thinking whether AI is
necessary or even
advisable um one example that comes to
my mind is a use the indiscriminate use
of generative a high for writing code
and without asking what is the kind of
reasoning that is behind the code
written by generative High I think that
this reasoning I mean there is no human
reasoning at least and this human
reasoning however is the basis for uh
being able to write code that other
people can understand and I think that
is especially problematic because a
philosophy Professor tested chat GPT for
instance with the logic assignments of
his students and realized that chat GPT
is incredibly bad at doing for instance
truth tables and Truth trees that are
exercises that can be completed with
rulle based rule based reasoning but
this kind of rule based reasoning is
really at the core of the work uh of a a
programmer of wres code and so I'm
really not sure what can be the result
um I also think and I I am really much
annoyed by all of these API AI IP
personally because I think that it is
creating expectations that cannot be
matched by the technology long term and
at the same time is diverting atten
mention from tasks where using AI really
makes a total sense I have also no doubt
that we don't read we don't really need
AI as such we need an AI that is
environmentally sustainable economically
sustainable and socially sustainable
otherwise HEI will be something that is
U not just controversial but simply
doesn't help anyone and it is for these
reason that I suggest as punishment for
thei Fanatics the task to read and
reread uh the book computer power and
human reason this is an old book it
dates back to the 1970s and it was
written by a computer scientist Joseph
venon Who had who had written one of the
first programs that allowed human
computer interaction is a program named
Ela played the role of a psychotherapist
and gave the impression of replying as a
psychotherapist to the person who was H
giving the input but of course there was
just a machine and not a human being and
vam wrote the book when he realized that
people uh were starting to not to see
the the that before them there was no
human being just a computer M and also
that they uh it was even really shocked
when practising psychotherapist
suggested that El Eliza could be
transformed in a sort of automated tools
for
Psychotherapy um and in this book The V
makes two key points the first one is
that there is a substantial difference
between human intelligence and the
computational power of a machine and
also that uh even when computers can do
some tasks um it is immoral to
substitute a computer for a human
function and these are the words of vit
and bound that involves interpersonal
respect understanding and love at times
when people are suggesting that chat GPT
can be used in mental health ABS I think
that there is still a point in reading
this book and in suggesting it to the AI
Fanatics we are now in the last level of
the hell and here I place the worst the
category of Sinners for me these people
are those who do not understand that
data are about people even if you can't
see the tears the sentence is a given in
quotation marks because it is not mine I
just borrowed it from a with statistical
book that was written by a statistician
work in a cancer institution in this
chapter whose title sounds statistics is
about people even if you can't see the
tears the statistician tells the story
of uh when he asked a cancer researcher
to provide some information about the uh
survival curves that he
had that he had printed in some of his
papers and the ccer researcher said no
because he feared that the statistician
could use this information in order to
undermine the uh the the findings of the
uh his findings and I uh this is quite a
shocking story because a survival curve
is precisely what it says that is it
gives a it gives an um an idea of how
many people are alive after a certain
time from
diagnosis it is therefore clear that
even though you have numbers to describe
the curve these numbers are individual
tragedies and these individual tragedies
should never be forgotten and
unfortunately it is uh too often the
case that data are just considered data
regardless of what they are referring to
and I think that this is really a very
bad scene because I think think that
there is a a moral and an intellectual
commitment and this is an imperative
commitment in my opinion not
to confuse things to keep seeing what
the data are really representing even
though when they they land on the desk
of the data scientist they are taken
completely out of their context but the
te are still there and I think that the
punishment for these people is uh to
make can see these tears and not only to
see the tears but also to think how
would they feel if this data were data
that referred to them or to their family
members I think that they would not be
indifferent to the data anymore wow we
have made to the end of my map of the
hell um as I said from the beginning
this was an opinionated talk uh but it
is now enough from my side and I would
be uh Curious to hear what are what
would be your map for data sence uh
thank
you hi there that was that was a great
talk thank you very very much and I I
really the creativity of it and your
slides were amazing so thank you very
much we do have one question um if I
could share and it
was um could you give an example of when
physic and political geographies are
confused yes one example that come to my
mind is borne Borneo is the the
geographical name of an island and you
this island is divided within three
countries that are
Indonesia brune and another count sorry
I can't remember but uh it happens and
it's not so infrequent that people in a
the field I put Borneo but B is not a
country and this is the reason why I say
that I get annoyed when people don't
standardize think because if you have
your country name standardized you you
immediately realize that you can can't
put Boro in this context because Borneo
is simply not a country um this is one
example